recently in the british journal the
guardian an article was published under
the title
do we need a new theory of evolution
the article paints a grim picture of the
field of evolutionary biology
we learn of great chaos
a battle with quote
the weight of a theological schism
we're told there is a revolution
led by a neglected group of underdogs
they fight passionately against the
tormenting genetic theory of evolution
by natural selection
the article describes those who oppress
these brave rebels as quote
high priests
high priests who dominate and ostracize
all those who dare question the quote
evolutionary orthodoxy
it's treason then
as you can see the guardian's picture of
what's happening in the field of
evolutionary science is pretty exciting
the question is is anything they said
actually true
that my friends is the question that we
will be diving into today right here
right now
normally i ignore stuff like this
newspapers all around the world are
failing they have to be more and more
sensational they need to make things
that will rub people the wrong way so
that they get shared and talked about i
mean look at this i just made an
advertisement for their their article
you know i took the bait i took their
click bait
well
the reason that i'm responding to this
article in particular
is because i received a letter from a
school teacher a high school teacher she
was teaching math and she just got
switched to having to teach biology she
had to take that on as well she is not
trained in biology
she found that article and she panicked
just to keep her identity private
i'm gonna call her miss johnson i'm
gonna show you part of the letter i
recently found an article in the
guardian claiming that scientists don't
actually understand evolution and they
are desperately grasping for a new
theory
is this true
is the concept of evolution as described
in our textbooks
wrong for those of you who are new to
this channel you don't know who i am you
might be wondering why is it that
teachers are writing me letters
my name is john perry i am a science
curriculum developer i work directly
with researchers in the fields of
chemistry
genetics and biology to develop science
lessons that high school and middle
school teachers can use in their
classrooms those lessons are delivered
mainly in the form of animations on the
website
dot statedclearly.com in short
my job is to support
science teachers
so miss johnson is the concept of
evolution as described in our textbooks
wrong no miss johnson your textbook is
fine assuming that you're using you know
one of the books common in the american
public school system evolution is taught
accurately in these books and the
version of evolution presented in them
is not
being abandoned by scientists as the
guardian article seems to suggest
that said i don't expect you to simply
take my word for it instead let's take a
look at the guardian article and compare
it to
well reality
the article starts by complaining that
the typical explanation for the
evolution of mammal eyes the explanation
found in textbooks starts quote midway
through the story taking for granted the
existence of light-sensitive cells
lenses and irises without explaining
where they came from in the first place
end quote
now this complaint is
technically true but maliciously
misleading yes most textbooks do start
somewhere in the middle of the story
when it comes to eyeball evolution and
yes they give very few technical details
about the origin of lenses and so on but
there's an obvious reason for this it is
an introductory textbook designed to
give students an overview of what
scientists have discovered as is true
with any introductory textbook on any
topic if you want all the details you
have to look in the primary scientific
literature or in the case of i evolution
there happens to be a specialist book on
the topic which i do recommend to anyone
who's
curious enough to pay 75
dang
well i suggest asking your local library
to buy it for you if your students are
most interested in how the first
light-sensitive cells evolved it's a
little bit of a different topic there's
a general overview in the scientific
literature right here and it's totally
free light and the evolution of vision
aside from that i recently read this gem
of a paper diving specifically into what
we currently know about the origin of
photoreceptive proteins the evolutionary
relationship between microbial
rhodopsins and metazoan rhodopsins
the article then claims that we have no
idea how wings evolved
okay we do understand how wings evolved
wings if you're talking about bird wings
they are modified arms
right now thanks to work in
developmental biology we now have a
really clear idea how feathers evolved
it's a really interesting story i get
made fun of sometimes because i don't
know if you can see
people like to point out that i have an
entire book just about feathers behind
me on my shelf what a nerd i am well
guess what losers i don't have one book
about feathers i've got multiple
volumes i love these old books where
they just they detail every little thing
on a chicken nobody makes these anymore
you have to buy them on ebay and they're
a lot of money
i've done multiple videos on the
evolution of flight i did one with the
howard hughes medical institute what
good is half a wing
i did a guest lecture at oregon state
university on the topic which was
recorded and is on this channel and
actually last year's christmas special
was about the evolution of wings
so that's strike one against the
guardian article for being so misleading
there it continues by talking about a
group of researchers who claim that they
quote modern synthesis
is currently holding science back
now this thing the quote modern
synthesis
it is a loose family of concepts and
evolutionary models that were widely
popularized arguably starting in the
1940s the modern synthesis is not
usually mentioned in textbooks but when
reading reports on the history of
science you'll often see the modern
synthesis described as a merger between
evolution by natural selection with
mendelian genetics
the modern synthesis is what we call a
research program it was a set of popular
interests that were guiding researchers
as they decided what was worth studying
one of the extremely impressive
achievements often associated with the
modern synthesis an achievement that was
oddly downplayed in the guardian article
was the mathematical formalization of
evolution by natural selection so
darwin's somewhat messy ideas were
translated into precise
mathematical equations you can see some
of these equations at work on the
wonderful youtube channel called primer
i posted a link to my favorite primer
animation down in the video description
make sure to check that out this math
was so useful that variations of these
equations are now found in the work of
chemists sociologists economists and
have inspired many algorithms currently
used in computer science especially in
the subfield of artificial intelligence
so i don't know one day if we find
ourselves enslaved by our new robot
overlords i suppose that in part you can
thank darwin today some scientists worry
that the enormous success of the modern
synthesis has caused the field of
evolutionary biology to cling too hard
to the concepts popularized back in the
40s and honestly that is a fair concern
no one wants to see us coasting on the
fumes of yesteryear's ambition
several years ago a group of concerned
researchers armed with nothing but their
wits
and
millions and millions of dollars in
funding donated to them by the john
templeton foundation
i don't mean to get all jerry coiny on
you all but the funding source of an
organization can influence its message
so this really is a fact worth noting
and for some reason the guardian article
neglected to do so
this concerned group of researchers
claim that it is now time for a new era
of research an era they call the
extended evolutionary synthesis
they even have their own website and a
cool little logo in my personal
interactions with members of this group
most of them seem totally reasonable
there are some exceptions there are
those who pretend to be scientific
revolutionists but you know
self-proclaimed revolutionists are
actually somewhat common even outside
the extended synthesis so i don't want
to be too hard on the movement most
folks in the ees they humbly understand
that their work is merely an extension
of the work that was done before as the
guardian put it most people in this
group simply quote want their subfields
plasticity evolutionary development
epigenetics cultural evolution not just
recognized but formalized in the canon
of biology so when you google evolution
they want their work if not their names
to be at least mentioned on the
wikipedia page that would be nice right
i want to end by talking about
phenotypic plasticity because this is a
concept that was discussed correctly in
some parts of the article and falsely in
other parts plasticity is an organism's
ability to change its traits in real
time so during its own lifetime in
response to specific environmental
conditions
for example when you lift weights you
grow bigger muscles when a person goes
out in the sun their skin can tan
developmental plasticity is when an
organism changes how it grows or
develops
according to environmental conditions
the article talks a lot about plasticity
in polypterus fish this is a group of
fish still alive today that have
well-developed gills and well-developed
lungs if raised in a tank full of water
their lungs stay small their fins stay
fish-like if however they are removed
and raised on land as they struggle to
pull themselves against gravity thin
muscles strengthen as you might expect
but also bones of the fins change shape
and do so in a way that makes them
measurably better at
floppy fishwalking the guardian article
claims that this type of plasticity may
have helped facilitate the evolutionary
transition from water to land
and i agree with them on this finally
they wrote something that made sense
sadly however the guardian goes on to
make the following claim
undergraduates beginning their education
are unlikely to hear anything about it
anything about plasticity
this statement is simply
false in every single college and every
single high school biology text i have
looked at comments about plasticity
usually in the form of nature versus
nurture they are peppered all throughout
the text and there's usually an entire
section specifically dedicated to the
topic of plasticity now in the
guardian's defense plasticity often goes
by a different name in textbooks
a species degree of plasticity is
usually referred to as its norm of
reaction and a trait that is highly
plastic is called a multifactorial trait
this means that many factors genetic and
environmental collectively influence the
trait
this right here is dr emily standin
she's the woman who discovered the
extreme plasticity in those walking fish
the guardian article made it seem like
she's a member of the extended
evolutionary synthesis her work which
was by far the most impressive work in
that article was cited as if it were
theirs well
it is not
theirs
when dr standin had a new idea instead
of complaining about the evolutionary
orthodoxy she set up an experiment she
carefully documented and then published
the results she was not persecuted for
those results she was not ostracized the
quote high priests of the quote
evolutionary orthodoxy did not have her
silenced to the contrary her research
was funded by the national science
foundation and other mainstream grants
the same ones controlled by the
orthodoxy her results were so thorough
they were published in and celebrated by
the prestigious journal nature
today whenever possible she does public
outreach events she cares so much about
her work that she didn't even let the
pandemic slow her down when speaking
venues were closed she posted
presentations on youtube
so to answer the guardian's question
do we need a new theory of evolution
no
but it would be nice if all of us
would try to be a bit more
like emily
if you like this video please share it
post a link on twitter facebook all that
stuff email it to people who you think
should see this
you